il était 4h17 du matin heure locale
quand la terre a trembler
le séisme était tellement puissant que
les répliques ont fait tomber des
édifices pendant toute la journée
fini de Turquie et de Syriens sont
encore coincés dans les décomptes
j'ai cru que le jour du jugement dernier
était arrivé 17 septembre restez sous
les décombres pendant 4 heures juste
au-dessus de sa femme
ma femme est encore sous l'amas de
débris dit-il sous le choc je lui ai
parlé pendant trois heures mais elle n'a
jamais répondu on ne doit jamais perdre
espoir mais elle est probablement
décédée
les opérations de sauvetage procurent
quelques moments de joie beaucoup
d'enfants sortent vivants des décombres
ce sont clairement plus de moyens de
machineries lourdes que les séries
qui dégagent souvent les victimes à main
[Musique]
il y a 12 familles piégées ici dit-il
ils ont pas encore réussi à sortir une
seule personne aucune autorité de la
sécurité civile ou de la défense n'est
venu voir où sont les survivants sous
les décombres
on travaille avec nos mains depuis 4
heures du matin
c'était aller très vite c'est-à-dire moi
personnellement j'ai eu 5 secondes ou
j'ai pensé que c'était le la dernière
nuit de ma vie et puis après en fait
tout s'est enchaîné voilà on se dit ok
quels sont les premiers gestes d'urgence
à adopter ou est-ce qu'il faut se où
est-ce qu'il faut s'abriter cette
travailleuse humanitaire aide d'habitude
à scolariser les enfants c'est rien les
plus vulnérables aujourd'hui elle était
au front de l'urgence dans la rue c'est
un peu une impression de de journée de
fin du monde à Alep
et ce soir en fait la la plupart
beaucoup d'aller pas en fait ne sont pas
re-rentrées dans leur maison c'est des
bâtiments qui sont très hauts avec
plusieurs étages et ils ont peur en fait
que les structures ne cèdent parce qu'il
y a plusieurs bâtiments qui se sont
effondrés au fur et à mesure de la
journée
qui a perdu son cousin dans le séisme
les gens n'ont rien à manger rien à
boire ils n'ont rien la situation est
désespérée ici et personne ne nous aide
quels sont les besoins les plus urgents
selon lui
non non
je ne sais pas quoi répondre dit-il je
n'y arrive pas les enfants pleurent
partout les parents ne savent plus quoi
faire quand la situation est très
mauvaise depuis tellement longtemps
après des heures de recherche et
d'espoir se faire trouvant enfin son
bébé mais le bambin ne respire plus
des milliers de personnes sont
retrouvées vivantes mais gravement
blessées
à tous les hôpitaux sont bondés il y a
des appels de la
de la banque de sang pour que les gens
viennent
donner du sang
de la diaspora l'impact des sanctions
occidentales sur l'envoi de don il
craignent que les Syriens qui vivent au
Canada aux États-Unis en Europe ne
puissent pas aider leur famille
dévastées toutes les transactions
financières avec la Syrie ont été
bloqués à cause des sanctions alors même
si quelqu'un
ONG ou une association veut envoyer de
l'argent en Syrie il est interdit à tous
ces liens de faire des transactions
financières l'aide humanitaire sera en
compte goutte en Syrie et très peu de sa
tête se rendrait dans les territoires
comme Alep qui sont sous le contrôle du
gouvernement de Bachar al-Assad car la
série demeure un pays déchiré par la
guerre ici Sophie Langlois Radio-Canada
Montréal